أتذكر نزهة واحدة في بالمورال
كانت تجري في أحد الرؤساء
في الحوزة ، التقطت بعض الجبن
ووضعته على طبق وكنت أنقله
إلى الطاولة التي
سقطت الجبن على الأرض
، كان لدي قرار في جزء من الثانية
لأتخذه  التقطت الجبن ووضعته على
الطبق ووضعته على
المنضدة واستدرت لأرى أن كل تحركاتي
كنت أراقبها بعناية شديدة من قبل صاحبة
الجلالة الملكة
التي نظرت إليها ، نظرت إليّ
وابتسمت للتو
و  بقي الجبن على الطاولة ،
إنه بالفعل يوم حزين ،
لكنه أيضًا يوم احتفال
بحياة قضتها جيدًا في أمتنا في
أوقات الشدة
التي انضمت إليها في احتفالاتنا بفرح
وابتسامة مؤذية
أعطتنا مثالاً لنا.
كل الإيمان بخدمة واجب
كرامة الحشمة
كانت
رائعة وأشك في أننا سنراها مرة أخرى كما لو
كانت ترقد بسلام وترتفع في المجد